[Music]
I think I've always told folks I think
happiness is like fireworks and cocaine
like they're shiny and they're cool and
they are terrible Masters and their
terrible destination like there it's a
it's a dumb place to try to attain like
to try to get to if you will and it's
baked into the DNA of our country this
Pursuit of Happiness that's like it's
wired into who we say we
are and I don't think it's good talk to
me about happiness well yeah and i' I
kind of had always felt like you now at
the same time I I'm a science journalist
ultimately and um in reading a lot of
the research on on happiness like we get
we get this list of things we got to do
to be happy right the big one now is you
must be social to be happy I'm like I'm
not saying that being social is bad but
I am saying like how do we measure that
like I know plenty of people that prefer
to be alone and they just have one or
two really good friends that seeming are
seemingly some of the most satisfied
people with their lives I've ever met
where it's like you must do X you must
do y you must must do Z all to be happy
and when you start to sort of Peel back
the layers and also use some common
sense you can see that like it's the
keto diet it's the raw vegan it's like
well I mean yeah yeah yeah yeah it
doesn't exactly Jive you science
journalist with your data data
sucks um
happiness is complex it's confusing and
um so what is to sort of understand it
well I'll tell you I'll tell you this
so there's all this list of stuff we
need to do to be happy right and then I
come across some research on these uh
benedic te monks who live in uh New
Mexico and there's a bunch of them
throughout the world
and research shows that there some of
they're significantly happier than the
average person now when you look at what
they do across the day their life would
kick your butt
like it seem like they're doing all
these things that like don't make sense
for them to be happy they wake up at 3
in the morning and go pray in the chapel
and they do that seven other times
across the day they do hard physical
labor for four hours they spend a
significant portion of the day not
talking at all they have to be in
silence so they're not super social they
don't have um long story short they have
a pretty hard austere lifestyle that
they've created for themselves that
they've created for themselves and yet
they're happy and so why is that and I
think a lot of it goes back to they're
not trying to be happy right they're
trying to devote to devote themselves to
this higher idea so for them it's God
they're trying to do the next right
thing that um is not about themselves
they're getting out of themselves in
every moment and I think that um by
following that by doing what you
inherently know is the next right thing
that's going to help uh other people
help the world I think people wind up
Happ yes that is harder right because we
often think that and I'm guilty of this
if I just buy that one car like that's
that's going to make me happy like my
problem is that I don't have the right
car right I don't have the right
purchase I if I my next happiness is
going to be this awesome new meal I'm
going out for like we have all these
things right that we think are going to
make us happy but I think really um when
you kind of peel back the layers on not
only the research but also I mean a lot
of just this ancient wisdom that's been
circulating through humans for as long
as we've been around it really is like
get out of yourself find something
bigger than yourself and try and do the
next right thing and help others and
people wind up happy that way tell me if
this maybe I'm stretching here um so I
wrestled I've wrestled with body
dysmorphia my whole life like um like
even looking at objective measures and
um I was having a meal with Salo Stefano
the one one of mind pump guys up in San
Jose and he's been a personal trainer
for years and he said something that was
was one of those before and after
moments for me and he said John you
can't hate your body into better shape
if you go to the gym every day because
you think you're
disgusting and you beat yourself up for
an hour to be less disgusting you'll
always run out of gas you'll never get
to that place if you wake up every day
and love yourself enough to say dude I
am so invested in feeling better like
I'm worth at least an hour that's how
much value I have then you'll that's
you'll do that indefinitely because
you're on a you're you're on a path now
you're not just sprinting to this
arbitrary Finish
Line it almost sounds like if the finish
line is happy you'll never catch it but
if these guys are waking up every day
and saying my path to peace my path to
whatever path to God is I'm not trying
to be less
unhappy yeah I think that works I'm just
trying to do the next right thing
because I'm worth doing the next right
thing and of course 95% of that
Monastery I've hung out with mon like
they all want to still be asleep but
they get up at 3: it's not like they
can't wait to wake up at 3: they'd much
rather sleep till 7:00 but they wake up
at 3: cuz it's the next right thing and
there's a thing about Covenant there's
something about that idea like I said I
was going to do it and I think the
person we lie to the most often in our
worlds is ourselves and so there's
something about keeping a covenant to
God or to whatever but something about
telling the truth to yourself yeah that
ultimately I don't know it feels like I
keep my hands keep doing this I keep
opening up but it feels like freedom and
maybe that's what happiness looks like
but um and also there's there's there's
challenge in how they live it's not like
they're doing easy things all day either
and I think that humans get a lot of
reward from doing from over coming
challenges yeah and there's probably
good reasons for that that go back to
our past whereas if let's say you're
looking for food and you can't find it
it's like thousands of years ago food is
scarce and you're you're going to one
place you can't find it you're going to
the next you can't find it you can't
find it you can't find it oh my God
we're going to die and then you find it
oh my gosh our lives are saved it's the
most rewarding food ever and it's every
it's every week you're it's the most
rewarding thing right yes and it could
be the exact same food as you'd had a
week ago but it was easy to find but you
really value that that food that was
harder to find and so I think that still
today that gets translated into the
things that we have to work harder for
to accomplish where we often have to go
through short-term discomfort but we get
this thing at the end that gives us a
long-term benefit we value that more so
we've both been in Academia it's like
when students um get an A in my media
class they're like kind of Happy but
when they get a a in chemistry or you
know geometry or that really hard stem
class going oh my gosh this is amazing
the grades are worth the same point
value but why do we value the chemistry
a over the Michael Easter's journalism
107 Class A because the chemistry is is
a lot harder so should we be weary of
Happiness should I be nervous about it
should I just like CU now I I have a
weird relationship with it now now I'm
I'm super cautious about it and I almost
think I'm hitting the pendulum the other
side right so I I you know when the
Accolade came last week about the book
like John your book did
well I was like that's cool and like I
did one little fist pump and the person
with me was like nope Del you're going
to celebrate this for a second I two
fist pumps yeah exactly how do you what
kind of relationship should we have with
happiness yeah it's a good question I
mean I think it's honestly it's a lot of
internal searching um I think that uh
you know my book it it doesn't give you
a perfect road map on how to live your
life because I think that everyone is
different yeah and you know as much as
we lean on data especially people like
you and I when you look at study data
there's always outliers and there's
always it's a range of outcomes and we
just kind of lump them into one and so
what if you're a person who's not
perfectly you know in in the average
group you could be out here or out here
and so I think I think living life is um
it's a journey it's an exploration right
you have to figure out what works for
you uh when why how and that's not often
uh easy or formulaic dude we just want a
recipe though man we just want to but by
going through that it you learn
something you get such deeper
rewards and so and also you have to
realize um that we're kind of I'm going
back to something we just talked about
um you mentioned body
dysmorphia a lot of what we um obsess on
or think about or decide that we want
it's so culturally conditioned oh yeah
right
so 200 years ago you would have your
idea of body dysmorphia would have been
a totally different look exactly yeah
right yeah and so what's up with that
right right we it's not real right well
conditioned yeah yeah humans are great
because uh we can think in stories and
abstract ideas that's how we you know
we're able to cooperate and take over
the globe but on an individual level we
can buy into our own BS yes I love mine
I love mine because mine's always right
Michael mine's always accurate and I'm
guilty of that too you know um and we're
we're constantly moving the goalpost as
well um so that's something I write
about in the comfort crisis with this
idea that you know today's uh today's
Comfort becomes tomorrow's discomfort
and as the world kind of advances over
time I think we can end up adopting some
behaviors that aren't necessarily great
for
us and that means we have to be okay
with well in a world where you and I can
pull our cell phones up right now and
punch a button and food will just show
up here MH we're not Des we're not
evolved for that no and that we can just
walk 15 yards that way and turn a knob
and water comes out we're not evolved
for that and
so help us with this um I think this
scarcity brain was such a natural move
from Comfort
crisis but it seems like there's been a
shift in in the human existence really
quick that we have to make peace with
and that
is these th these things on our left
used to take a ton of energy to go get
and they don't and so now our new
adventure is not finding these things in
the moment the new adventure is
injecting fractals into our life
injecting discomfort into our life on a
regular basis so how do we create this I
guess peace with discomfort and how do
we begin to rationally inject discomfort
into our lives something that surprised
me as I was uh writing the Comfort
crisis is we have injected so much
comfort into our life we often don't
even see all the ways it's in there so I
think people intuitively know like yeah
I move a lot less than I probably would
have in the past yeah food's a lot
easier to come by but think of something
like boredom our relationship with
boredom has changed people are rarely
bored anymore we spend more than 12 to
13 hours engaged with digital media
think about the last time that's insane
all that stuff is new in the last 100
years it didn't exist think about the
how a human being spends their time you
went from 16 hours probably outside
working interacting with others all
these things and then now we do 12 hours
12 to 13 hours on average um stuff
that's coming through a screen so that's
from computers TVs smartphones and that
changes everything about it it changes
everything about us uh even something
like silence so humans came up in Worlds
that were very silent and anytime you
heard a loud noise it was probably bad
yeah someone trying to eat you someone's
trying to eat you there's a storm coming
through with a rock Hill to kill your
yeah and uh We've since increased the
world's loudness by fourfold and now
people say they feel uncomfortable in
silence but what tends to happen is that
after people go through the discomfort
of Silence they tend to calm down
because loud noises we still associate
that kind of in the back of our brain
run yeah and um release the stress
hormones and everything from our
relationship with with death to food to
um Everything Has Changed
and to your point about how it's not
we're just trying to do the next right
thing I call these good problems to have
right I would rather uh have the option
of having my food delivered than
literally every single day having to go
out and find it on foot in the cold or
in the desert where you live yeah in the
desert where I live yeah I wouldn't I
wouldn't survive out there very long
give me like 10 minutes
um but making the choice to do hard
things I think we know Keeps Us healthy
we know it tends to lead us into
happiness over the long term and so for
me it's um you have to think about uh
all the ways that you can sort
of look into what discomfort might be
able to bring you because I think even
something like boredom like all these
things we we evolve to feel these
discomforts because they kept us alive
in the past but they can still enhance
our life in the present so you know we
know exercise is the best thing you can
do for your health we know that probably
how much we love junk food is probably
not good for us and maybe going through
some Hunger sometime is going to have um
long-term upsides going through boredom
is associated with less stress more
creativity um even just more time
outside like we like to be indoors
because it's climate controlled
everything is certain you don't have to
worry about anything you go outside and
now all of a sudden well it's kind of
cold or it's kind of hot or there could
be an animal in the woods right um but
time in nature is one of the best things
you can do for mental health associated
with all these kinds of great things
even um there's some pretty compelling
research about walking on a treadmill or
on a sidewalk
versus walking on grass or rocks or
paths in just that there's so many
there's so many Century buttons If you
will on your feet and in your legs and
then little bitty muscles that are
constantly balancing you and we just
stripped all that out and flattened
everything out and said walk on the
sidewalk and there's probably less
broken feet less broken ankles and what
have we taken out right and it's just
simply it's it's hard to convince
somebody myself included that your day
has to be intentionally uncomfortable
for you to be well and whole that seems
so countercultural counter everything
right
right where do we
start well I I mean I think
that another observation I've made is
that some people will be really great at
one thing could be you know I go to the
gym every day for an hour but what are
the other discomforts that you're
avoiding could be a food thing could be
a boredom thing like they just can't sit
with their thoughts like you know I know
guys will go run Ultra marathons like
drop of a hat but then you go hey why
don't you sit why don't you sit in
silence with your thought thoughts for
five minutes and they're like no nope do
that no NOP yep yeah and so I think you
need to figure out you know what is your
what is sort of limiting you and what is
the thing that you are most afraid of is
into it yeah head right into it whether
it's the gym whether it is you know I'm
going to try and get a hold of my eating
and I realize that I'm probably going to
be hungry at some point but I also think
that it's never as bad as we think it's
going to be never never never no so I
think that humans sort of evolve to be
uh underc confident and overc competent
so say that again underc confident and
over competent so let's say we had to go
um you know that makes sense cuz if I'm
over confident I get killed right so
think like we got to okay we got to move
our camp you know we got to cross this
big river if you're the person who goes
yeah I I can cross that River no problem
you're dead but you're not that
confident you're like you get swept away
like those people don't die those are
the hold my beer people
right if you are the person who's going
we shouldn't cross I don't want to cross
that I don't think I can do that but you
get in a position where you're forced to
do it and you can accomplish it because
you've undersold yourself that would
give you a survival Advantage every
single time yes so I think that that we
still have that DNA and I think that um
that can limit us like people are
capable of way more than they realize
like way more and you see that tend to
come out when we put ourselves in
positions to prove that to ourself mhm
we need the EV of the doing and so I
think even just taking that first step
you get in there and you're like Yeah I
wanted to quit but I got through it and
what else can I do and what else can I
do and what else can I do but it really
does take that first step I mean and
people no one's going to drag you to the
gym no one's going to cut off your
subscription to Uber Eats no one's going
to shut down your cell phone because you
can't stop watching Tik Tok like it's
not it's just not going to happen in
fact the opposite you talk about a great
discy
brain for me I remember going down a
rabbit hole about 10 years ago with the
tech folks when the the Neuroscience
folks started partnering up and I
remember thinking oh I can't win that
like my only move is disengagement I
have to take the apps off my phone I
have to consider not carrying my phone
everywhere I've got I can't play the
game like when I go to Vegas I have this
much money and it goes in one pocket and
when it's gone it's gone because I can't
control myself the other way my wife can
because I think she's a serial killer
but like I I can't and so it is what it
is right but it's almost as though I
can't have that food in my house I'll
eat it right it's it's almost I have to
play disengagement for a season until I
can
slowly um begin to be more
intentional